بثت القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه تحقيقا
تضمن صورا التقطت من طائره للشرطه
الاسرائيليه تظهر بوضوح لاول مره قيام
دبابه اسرائيليه بقصف منزل في كيبوتس
بايري في غلاف غزه يوم السابع من اكتوبر
تشرين الاول الماضي وكان في بئيري حينها
عدد من الاسر الاسرائيليين
ومحتجزة
واوردت تحقيق شهاده احدى سكان الكيبوتس
حيث اكدت انها اصيبت بشيه من هذا القصف
واظهر التحقيق ايضا صورا لتجمع كبير لقوات
الامن الاسرائيليه خارج الكيبوتس في ذلك
اليوم بمن فيهم جنود وافراد من الشرطه دون
ان يبادروا الى اي تحرك لانقاذ
الاسرار منم مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد اذا اضافه لتحقيقات سابقه
فيما يتعلق ايضا بقتل الحفل الموسيقي
وا حوادث الجيش في هذا اليوم ما الذي
يضيفه هذا التحقيق الجديد لما حصل في
السابع من اكتوبر
اسرائيليا هذا يعزز المعلومات التي كانت
ترد تباعا دون وجود شهادات في البدايه ثم
توالت البينات والشهادات من ان عدد ممن
قتلوا في غلاف غزه في ذاك اليوم قتلوا من
نيران الجيش الاسرائيلي بدايه من ان
مروحيه كان تطلق النيران على الحفل الذي
كان في منطقه رعيم لمئات او الاف الشبان
ومن ثم ياتي هذا التحقيق الذي يؤكد مجددا
ان دبابه اسرائيليه كانت تطلق النيران على
منازل كيبوتس او القريه التعاونيه بايري
في غلاف غزه بينما كان هناك مقاتلون من
النخبه من القسام حسب التحقيق يحتجزون
اعدادا كبيره من الرهائن الاسرائيليين
داخله واللافت في كل ذلك ان التقرير يتحدث
عن حدث بعد سبع ساعات تقريبا من الاقتحام
الاول لمنطقه غلاف غزه وانه تواجدت قوات
عسكريه كبيره نحو 500 من الجنود عند
المدخل وفي محيط ذاك الكيبوتس دون ان
تتدخل بينما كانت الدبابه تواصل شهود
العيان وبينهم سيده تدعى هداس جان والتي
اصيبت من شذيه قالت بانها قد سالت الجيش
كيف يطلقون النيران على المنازل فردوا
عليها بانهم يطلقونها فقط ل للتسبب
بانهيار الجدران بينما كانت القنابل يسقط
بعضها في المنطقه وشخص اخر وهو عسك عضو في
فرقه الحراسه لهذا الكيبوتس يدعى يائير
افيتال قال بانه كان هناك 500 من الجنود
والقوات في الخارج ولم تتدخل وان الموضوع
استمر هذه التحقيقات الاسرائيليه بطبيعه
الحال وفي ظل حاله من الارتباك في اسرائيل
على خلفيه استمرار وجود نحو 129 من الاسرى
والمحتجزين في قطاع غزه والخوف عليهم من
ان يقتلوا بنيران الجيش الاسرائيلي اذا
تعمقت وتواصلت عمليته
البريه تشير الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ربما
لجا ايضا وخلال اليوم السابع
من اكتوبر اي قبل 74 يوما والان ربما يلجا
الى اعتماد عقيده هني بعل التي يعتمدها
لقصف الرهائن او الاسرى وحاجز
ومحتجزة تطلق النيران على هذا الكيبوتس
بينما في داخله
رهائن توضيح وليد هل من توضيح كيف وفي اي
سياق تنشر هذه التحقيقات في حاله حرب وفي
حاله رقابه شديده روايات يعني تنافي كل ما
بنيت عليها فكره الانتقام
وا الحرب انصح التعبير في
غزه هذه الحرب طالت عاده في اسرائيل خاصه
خاصه الاعلام يلتزم الصمت عندما تكون
الدوله في حاله حرب وهذا وفق عقيده صحفيه
يعتمدونها منذ اجتياح لبنان عام 822
والقائمه على اساس شييك يريم اي اصمتوا
فنحن نطلق النار لكن الحرب طالت والخسائر
التي يتكبدها الجيش الاسرائيلي زادت رغم
كل القوات الهائله التي يحسدها ويبدو ان
في اسرائيل من اصبح لا يريد ان يستمر هذا
الوضع فاصبح
يفرج عن بعض المعلومات خاصه وان هناك من
يتهم رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو بانه
يحاول دحرجه المسؤوليه عن الفشل
المخابراتي والعسكري الذريع الذي منيت به
اسرائيل واجهزتها الامنيه وجيشها في
السابع من اكتوبر يحاول دحرجتها على
القيادات الامنيه والعسكريه وربما من افشى
بهذا السر لوسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
اراد ايضا التصدي لمثل هذه الحمله لان في
اسرائيل ومنذ اللحظه الاولى هناك ازمه ثقه
متعمقه بين الشارع الاسرائيلي وقيادته
السياسيه ممثله بتوليفه
اليمين المفرط في تطرفه الذي يقوده
نتنياهو وهناك تحسن في الثقه تجاه الجيش
والاجهزه الامنيه اي تعززت هذه الثقه في
مقابل ان هذه الثقه تتراجع وهو ايضا ما
تدل عليه حركه الشارع من ناحيه وتدلل تدلل
عليه ايضا الاستطلاعات الرام الاسبوعيه
وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره من رام
الله شكرا جزيلا لك